[Music]
you got in this business at a very young
age and started doing well right away
and you must have met some legends you
must have met some of the guys who
they're gone now but just huge stars and
that must have been my most fascinating
experience if you're 16 17 18 years old
in your meeting I don't even know
oh yeah who's one of the biggest stars
you met of the goat the Golden Age Oh
probably the biggest star Cary Grant
you bet Cary Grant I met Cary Grant but
I was such a young punk actor and so
like not knowledgeable about film yet
right that all I knew was Cary granite
from the Flintstones oh right that was
kind of like who's this crazy old man I
was just trying to bang his daughter
yeah and okay it's true people come on
throw up what a charming story what if
all of your stress so I meet the great
dance they're trying to bang his hot
mother Theresa she wasn't a look at it
but I wanted to bang no we I think we
were we were teenagers we were in we
were in middle school together and so I
went to the house to meet Cary Grant and
he showed up at the door in a white
bathrobe I'll never forget it which I
thought was an interesting wardrobe
choice right but like the he is the most
iconic face probably in film yeah and
and joke - oh nice and so charming and
and my very first thing was ever on
television was going to air that day and
we all watched it together so the first
time I ever saw myself on TV I was with
Cary Grant he was full of great advice
not the least of which was young man
don't ever eat a hot dog on a dais I was
like what just well because then
there'll be a picture of you with a hot
dog in your mouth
really good by the way
so we tell my day it's like you're
upwind of like at a roast or something
Josh club night club you know yeah
exactly
you don't want that you know honestly
and I don't do it yeah
all right good for you I've seen people
I've seen you on TV and people are
trying to hand you a hot people are
trying to hand him a hot dog and he's
like all right they're not good really
serving hot dogs at Gail you know what's
a day is where you add your grant